most people today sitting here would
probably say that climate change was one
of those issues it's extremely hard to
miss the enormous environmental impact
that we're now having now that Asia has
embraced industrialization
wholeheartedly but I actually think
there are more serious problems that
could have an impact before the long
unfolding process of global warming has
whatever consequences it's going to have
I take the threat very seriously of
climate change don't get me wrong but
before we ever get to our gauze
worst-case scenario we could have blown
the world up because happening right now
at full speed is the breakdown of the
system of non-proliferation set up
nearly 40 years ago which very
successfully limited the number of PARs
who could use a choir or have the option
to use nuclear weapons and I think
that's a worry because even if an Iran
acquires only a very small number of
nuclear missiles that significantly
increases the risk of a nuclear exchange
of some kind even if only an accidental
won the super powers in the Cold War
played a very simple game there were
just two players and they risked
mutually assured destruction if they
fault and then it turned out to reduce
the probability of a of a nuclear war
quite dramatically but in a world of
multiple nuclear powers where there are
lots of small Cold War's one between
Pakistan and India one Navy between
China and Japan one between say Israel
Iran and so on when that world comes
about then the probability of a nuclear
war is quite high because the stakes are
lower only the United States and the
Russians still have enough weapons to
blow up the world everybody else can
just blow up a few cities but the
probability is higher because you have
maybe q
missile crisis every year instead of
just one in 50 years so that makes me
very uneasy and I feel as if we are
stumbling towards a much more dangerous
world in which a nuclear weapon will get
used sometime soon and this would be a
bigger explosion than Hiroshima or
Nagasaki because these weapons are far
more destructive than they used to be